they they find um a bunch of burner cell
phones they find like a bag of like 50
000 of cash they find a bunch of like
the hardware wallets that had the
bitcoins in them and then they found
like folders on their computer that were
like fake passport ideas and like
like
places to go places to run away like
they found like folders that said that
[__] on their computers
[Music]
i don't even entirely understand what
happened but i have a backstory about
three people today's edition of the milk
road you will get the full backstory and
10 bullet points yeah you need to go
earlier so but but we did bullet point
and what so here's what happened 2016
this crypto exchange called bitfinex got
hacked and at the time i think like 120
000 bitcoin got stolen that was like 70
million dollars got stolen
and it was like it was bad uh that was
like a big hack the price of bitcoin
that week dropped by 40
so it was like
it caused like this huge uh you know
like uh a fear shock in the market
but
the thing about bitcoin is
bitcoin is on a public ledger right like
it's a it's a public blockchain so
everybody could see the coins everybody
saw oh the coins are in this wallet and
like
and so all the other exchanges were like
look this is bad for the industry
we will try to prevent like if that
wallet tries to cash this out we won't
let them cash out uh the money so
for many years that money kind of just
sat in those wallets or was moving in
like really small small transactions
back and forth between like a web of
wallets clearly somebody was trying to
like launder the money essentially they
were trying but but how how did he how
did they even get out of the first place
so i don't know i don't know what the
exploit was that let them hack the
accounts and they didn't hack all the
accounts on bitfinex they actually just
hacked like some of the whale accounts
so they were able to take 120 000
bitcoin from not all the accounts and
the funny thing is that biffinx didn't
have the money to like make those users
whole so what they did was they they
reduced everybody on bit fedex's balance
by 33 or something to like balance it
out so i'm like hor like imagine if your
bank did that that would be like insane
i'd be like oh they robbed that guy's
vault and you're taking my money away to
like even it out for everybody like no
thank you
um so anyways it was bad and there's a
reason why biff next is not like you
know the biggest exchange now um so
anyways that the money kind of sat there
now fast forward five and a half years
go by
last week people start to notice bigger
transactions coming from the uh the
bitfinex hack wallets um and so they're
like there's these alerts on twitter
like whale alert well it's like the
coins are moving the coins are moving
hundred thousand dollars a million
dollars the coins are moving 10 million
whatever and so um
and so the fed go are not the fed sorry
department of justice goes kicks down a
door in new york
into this this this husband and wife
couple's house and they look like you
know your complete like average joe
clean cut like you would this is not
like you know doesn't look like a grimy
criminal
mastermind operation uh and i'll explain
a little bit more about that in a second
the funny bit about that uh but
basically they seize uh like their
computers they they find um a bunch of
burner cell phones they find like a bag
of like fifty thousand dollars of cash
they find a bunch of like the hardware
wallets that had the bitcoins in them
and then they found like folders on
their computer that were like fake
passport ideas and like
like
places to go places to run away like
they found like folders that said that
[__] on their computers
and um and they seized three and a half
billion dollars worth of bitcoin because
the price of bitcoin's gone up so much
so that 70 million has become three and
a half billion dollars worth and so
these guys were trying to launch
they don't think these are the hackers
but they were trying to launder that
money they may have been the hackers
they don't know that's not proven but
they were trying to launder the money
and the the doj had been like if you've
seen that meme of charlie from it's
always anywhere they have like the cork
board and he's like trying to like find
that find the the crime or solve the
crime that's what they had been doing
because they had this web of all these
wallets and finally they found that oh
it's trying to cash out in this wallet
owned by this guy
ilya dutch liechtenstein or whatever but
how how did what what type of idiot
would use this well eventually you need
to get the money
so the problem is like they were trying
to get the money out through like
walmart gift cards they were buying like
500 walmart gift cards with bitcoin they
were doing like playstation games they
were like they were trying all these
small things but they could never move
the bulk of the money so if you want to
move like in mass you got to do
something that had that lets you move
size and usually those
could you buy an nft and then sell it
no well eventually you need to get the
money out of the wallet that's the
problem so so
so the problem so
in order to do that there's like an
off-ramp right how do you get it into
you know us dollars for example if
that's what you wanted to do
um you know he left it there for five
and a half years and they were probably
living off and spending in some ways but
like you wanted to actually like get a
lot of it out and get get it uh remove
the paper trail of the blockchain you
need to get it as an off-ramp but to get
as an off-ramp you have like a
you know your id like these exchanges
they require you to upload your license
and like they have laws they have to
comply with called kyc know your
customer and so eventually they found
that somehow the doj they didn't explain
exactly but they
they identified that the money was
moving towards a wallet that was owned
by a known person that's how they ended
up finding these guys
now the funny part is that's awesome so
that
well so the i when i read about this i
was like wait that name sounds so
familiar both their names sound familiar
so the guy
his name is ilya i-l-y-a i think it was
like a very like weird name his last
name was lichtenstein so he spoke at the
first hustle con i never talked to him
but um he had a company called mix rank
which was just a normal startup went
through yc and he spoke at hustlecon and
then his girlfriend or wife
she was a copywriter and i remember
talking a little bit with her because
she her name's heather morgan i think
and she had a
um a website all about writing sales
emails totally is that right remember
before the hack did it like a red dress
she had like a linkedin post on like
five hacks for your your cover letter
for your job interview like you know
like that sort of thing
and so
yeah she was doing that she and so they
and the funny thing is like the reason
the internet kind of went crazy with it
was because here you had two very
unlikely characters so um we had a bunch
of friends text us or text me because i
was writing this this edition of the
milk road and i was like um anybody know
this guy and you you knew him but some
other people knew him they're like dude
you would never
get vibes of like this guy might just go
launder billions of dollars like
smart like kind of like like his
engineer type uh he like showed very
little emotion no i did not think that
this guy like yeah and and in her she's
like this like super strange kanye west
level weird uh you know like person she
basically she had like an alter ego that
was called razzle
and razzlecon was her rap name and then
she has like these super [__] cringy
rap songs on youtube like
dude okay i have you know i have
you know i think it'd be cool to be a
rapper but if i hear myself there's no
way i'm publishing that because
it sounds so bad
you better win come real far but don't
know where i'm heading [__]
crocodile of wall street
silver on my fingers and boots on my
feet
and so uh it's horrible
it's so bad that the top comment was
paris hilton
i'm gonna prove to everyone that you
could have uh that having money means
you can rap good and then it said
heather morgan hold my beer i don't even
know pearson has like a rap song
so yeah yeah there's just like she's
like one of the strangest characters
like i watched i went deep dude for this
i was writing this thing and i was like
oh let me get some examples and then i
couldn't look away because like the the
train wreck dude it's like there's
videos so uncomfortable and like she she
like
forced everybody to like they built like
this golden
mini taj mahal that she sat in and then
her bridesmaids lifted it up on her
shoulder and brought her in but even
though the audience at her wedding is
like uncomfortably clapping like
off-beat because they're like uh
this is this normal there's like there's
like clearly only 14 people in the room
and then she does a rap performance at
the wedding that was like equally
cringey and she's just like humping the
air oh my god
to the guy iliad
when he goes
dude this freaking guy uh i'm looking at
these pictures
that's hilarious this woman's
really hard to look at she's just
friends she's that should have been her
wrapping cringe city that would have
been like okay i get it you're gonna be
the cringiest cool uh that's like henry
cejudo
the king of cringe
uh
yeah that's what she should have done
like it is super strange
but um but yeah basically they recovered
it and so now what's gonna happen
anyways there's a bunch of interesting
little bits to it so the doj is gonna
give the money back to bitfinex it looks
like bitfinex had when they they
launched their own token at one point
time called the leo token that's like
used in their if you trade in their
exchange it'll give you a discount using
the leo token so they had to put it a
thing when they launched a leo token was
like hey if we ever recover anything
from that hack um we'll use 80 up to 80
of it to buy back and burn our leo token
which will cause like the price you know
leo holders to benefit from if we ever
recover from this
and so now they're gonna get like three
and a half billion dollars to buy back
so the price of leo token
like
shot up like whatever sixty percent in
24 hours because people are like oh wow
that's gonna be a lot but they said
we're not gonna just
cause a bunch of cell pressure in the
market we're gonna do a controlled sale
over like a multi-year period um so that
it's like scheduled and doesn't like
affect the bitcoin market or whatever
um
god this is such a good story this would
make this is exactly that's what
everyone was saying is like here comes
you know incoming incoming netflix doc
have you seen this i saw i just watched
this clip like every day for the past
three days
and it just absolutely cracks me up i
was hoping ben can uh play it in the
thing but i don't think it'll work i
don't think the sound will come through
so
have you seen this clip of this
interview of bill gates back in the day
jumping over a chair yeah have you seen
this yeah
wait like just the normal one of him
jumping
just
so he's doing some interview with some
woman about microsoft
and she goes she goes is it true that
you can leap over a chair
is that that impressive he goes
well first of all it is impressive
for bill gates to be able to do that
second of all
just i don't know why this is being
talked about and then he goes so she
goes is it true that you could jump over
a chair and he goes
it depends on the size of the chair
so you know just like then the cuts it's
like a hard cut to a chair and the milk
it's clearing it
is it true that you can leap over a
chair from a standing position
it depends on the size of the chair i'll
cheat a little bit
yeah that's an old clip you've just now
seen that i no i came back into my life
because i was thinking uh somebody said
something like oh yeah you know back in
the day or you know in the good old days
somebody said some phrase like that and
in my head i go
what are they even thinking about when
they
when they say that and i go i'm gonna
have i was like what's the funniest
back of the day thing and i that clip
came to mind
and so i decided anytime somebody says
back in the day or or you know in the
good old days i'm gonna think only of
that moment where bill gates says
depends on the depends on how i had the
chair i always just think of uncle rico
the uncle rico clipping napoleon
dynamite where he goes i used to be able
to throw a pig skin over them mountains
all right so listen i did something that
i did not think i was ever going to do
um so last year
in 2021
or no uh 2020 whenever covet happened
i launched this course that i i don't
even know if i ever talked about it
called the ideation boot camp i did it
with gagan i invested in this company
just like you did in maven you have
already done two of them i think and you
have a third coming up i decided to
launch one i launched one the other day
i only talked about it on twitter i've
not talked about it on here yet but so
if people want to do it it's called the
ideation bootcamp and it's basically my
research
um
my research framework and how i research
stuff it's but it's uh you go to
maven.com so maven how do you say how do
you like you say maven it rhymes with
like raven uh yeah there you go with an
m but with the m at the end
no no that's right that's right yeah and
you could see my name is on the front
page but what they don't have yet and
this is what i told gagan they so me and
sean both invested in this company and
as part of investing in it he made us
promise to do courses yeah um which was
actually a good kick in the ass because
now i actually had to do it and it has
been fun but um
he needs like custom urls he doesn't
have that yet oh yeah yeah it's like
maven.com
blank slash whatever in order to get to
your thing but i just have they made it
for me they made a powerwriting
powerwritingcourse.com they're
but they have to make it for you but i'm
doing this thing it i think it's gonna
be pretty badass i think i'll continue
doing it maybe once a year but maybe i
won't ever do it i don't know give an
example so give a teaser of like
okay so so this is about coming up with
a great idea figuring out so coming up
with ideas and then picking the ones
that seem like better ideas and worst
ideas in a short amount of time is that
the hook yeah i'll give one old example
so basically when trends launched i
wrote this article about plants and i'm
like man i think someone could build
like an online nursery or an online
plant business and the reason why i came
up with that idea is i read
the annual report for 1-800 flowers and
they said the of and 100 flowers the big
company does a billion or something in
revenue so they've got a large
perspective and they said that our
fastest growing segment is millennials
buying succulents online this is growing
like crazy and then i looked on at their
financials and it looked like the
majority of the profit came from people
buying accessories so chocolate or fancy
pots and i'm like well there's a [__]
idea you make succulents and you make it
like really cool pots that are artists
and you like figure out what the
contribution margin is and then
what alex said about what did alex say
yesterday in the podcast like
opportunity of value or value of
opportunity like he like phrased it
actually better than i phrased it
historically but basically you could do
a bunch of math it's really like simple
arithmetic and you're like in order to
get your repeat purchase rate
uh
the total adjustable market times your
contribution margin and like that's how
you can come up with a good idea in that
space just off that one insight and so
that's an example so i just list out all
like my frameworks and how i research
and it started with reading the
reading the annual report for 100
flowers which uh that sounds like the
most you know kind of unique starting
point for
finding
not even just finding specific
opportunities but just like training
your brain to think about the world
wider than the way you currently think
about it that's that's how i would
phrase it because like
i don't think you'd necessarily find the
best ideas by being like okay i'm gonna
go read you know the heart the hbs
business school in the harvard business
schools annual report and in there i'm
gonna find a business idea i think
that's a little too hardcore no
the way it works is you have this
general thing so this general thing is
basically what's this combination of
things that i'm interested in
things that i'm good at and things that
can make money all right i know what
that general i think is i'm going to go
to very particular places to find
information that's going to help guide
this and what it's going to do is going
to help me find a handful of problems
that i'm interested in solving and these
problems for sure have demand for them
i'll give you an example of this how
this played out in my life so i invest
in this company the guy actually came to
our podcast our live podcast show in san
francisco which was live in your office
very so you know it was a very small
crew maybe 50 people 75 people something
like that i don't know what it was but
it was the very first live thing we ever
did
and um
this guy comes up afterwards and he's
like
uh hey that was great um and i'm like
what are you cool what's your story what
do you do and he's like oh i'm i
currently run the perception team on the
self-driving cars division of uber
um he was very charming very good
looking i was sold too handsome guy
uh
ver very confident so he wasn't like hey
sean can i just pitch you my idea i'd
really just want to tell you like that
that's always like uh
sure man uh you talk while i think of a
way to escape is usually how that
conversation goes and so this was
different this guy was you know he i was
genuinely interested then he started
saying things and then i was like oh so
he's like yeah but i'm leaving to work
on my own startup
okay what is it uh what is it uber
artificial intelligence guy you know
like a guy who works on the ai team at
uber and so he was starting his own
self-driving car company and he's like
you know here's what we're gonna do
we're focusing on he's like you know
it's funny i i was you know i was
looking at what we were doing at uber
and he was like
what stood out what jumped out to me
this is kind of like one of your
ideation things it's like
sometimes some a stat will come out and
um at twitch the ceo emmett he used to
call the he used to say sometimes you
look at data
not for a specific answer but just to
find something that makes you go huh
or like that's weird it can't be right
can it and um and so he used to the ceo
and he used to mention like you don't
always go looking do it write a sequel
query just to get a specific answer
sometimes you just browse until
something jumps out at you as being like
not what you not on trend
and so anyways this guy had said 75 of
all um
uber rides are like you know one
passenger going less than it was like 60
60 something percent go or one passenger
and 60 were going less than three miles
so it's like short trips of just one
person inside of a dense city and he's
like you know so it's kind of crazy
right we have this like four person
maybe six percent six-seater car that
weighs thousands of tons with a with one
driver driving one person one mile like
that seems inefficient and so he was
trying to create a new vehicle that was
like a one-person vehicle one or
two-person vehicle that was electric and
self-driving and optimized for very
short trips and i was like oh that's
really cool anyways
i invest 50 000 bucks
you fast forward like a year
and uh you know he's like grinding away
in this garage in san mateo
uh trying to get a car to drive itself
and i would go down to he was working
literally out of a storage unit so i
would go to a storage container like
kind of a what's it called like uh
like public storage public storage yeah
literally and then he'd roll up the
garage on like unit 333 or whatever and
then he'd put me in it he'd be like all
right let's see if it works and then we
drive in a circle around the storage
facility a storage like a parking lot
and it was like whoa that was bizarre to
sit there and just like it was thing
driving me yeah so it was working but it
was very you know like that's a closed
environment it's pretty easy to get that
to work but he was working on okay now
let's take it out a mile okay now let's
go get a sandwich from the shop and like
that's what he was doing for like a year
so anyways
um
you at the time the idea the initial
idea was like
to be kind of like an uber competitor
right like somebody will just push a
button this ride will show up roll up to
them with no driver inside
they hop in they actually drive
themselves to the location then they
leave they just walk out and the thing
will drive to the next passenger by
itself i was like that's really cool
idea
we were trying to figure it out
and i felt like we were hitting a wall
and this is where something like your
course will help because
if you're oh if you're if all your ideas
are boxed into your own life experiences
and you're like a you know 27 year old
engineer who's worked at you know tech
companies like your life experiences are
pretty narrow
and only once we got out of that and
started like figuring out these little
like
you know like these these these unique
spots like when you when you read an
annual report you go huh so i was
reading an annual report uh we talked to
we just took a random meeting we took a
random meeting with some transportation
lawyer and he mentioned that he does
work for this company and i looked up
that company and it's basically like
this i don't know like 30 billion dollar
company that i've never heard of
and what did it do they partner with
like 15 cities and they go to the city
and they say hey um
you need buses and scooters and ferries
and trains and all that stuff yeah you
just commission us we'll bid for your
for the right to run transportation in
your city and they would get and so this
the whole 30 billion dollar company or
whatever was like
off of like 15 city contracts and then i
thought about i was like oh of course
like san francisco doesn't run their own
buses like you know or whatever not
every city is going to want to be in the
transportation business they just
contracted out to some vendor and i was
like man that's an amazing business
because that vendor now has lock-in like
the city's not going to change so
they're just going to like they just get
to eat up they have a monopoly on city
transport and then that got me thinking
about those city bike share programs if
you've seen those city bikes awesome and
then their annual reports were online
and i went and i read about it and city
bike did the same model they went to new
york and they built like 100 million
dollar revenue business doing city bikes
in new york and they were the only ones
who had the license to do it and they
did it in san francisco and then they
sold to lyft for i don't know some
hundreds of millions of dollars
and i thought
that's a really cool model and so then
we started brainstorming dude could you
go to a city that needs this type of
transport like a different type of
transport than what they already have
with their buses and whatever and just
say we'll be the vendor for you
that's exactly what they did they went
to las vegas did it work
uh yeah well i haven't talked to him
recently but yeah they got a contract
basically with las vegas where the city
was like yeah we have this thing called
a transportation desert it's like a
place where our routes don't really go
but a lot of people need to go in this
area and they're complaining to us about
it so you know yeah we'll pay you guys
we'll we'll pre-buy
you know like quarter million dollars of
rides from you
um and so it's like instead of trying to
get half a quarter million people to
download your app like uber yeah
whatever you've got one city official to
say i'll buy 250 000 worth of rides and
that'll last us a few months and we'll
see how that goes and that's what you
and i do to people so
because we just study and break down
stuff i think
you you and i go through the same
discovery and aha moment i hope that our
audience does which is basically you see
it once you know what's possible or once
you know like what other people is
possible your standard of what's
possible kind of changes and you're like
well of course i could do that they did
that and they did by doing this this and
this i already know exactly how they did
it it's like um it would kind of be like
me telling you well just go get big
muscles it's like i don't i can't get
big muscles like i don't know what that
means versus like well just lift this
weight do it four times a week and and
here i'll remind you every single time
and you can do it it's like when you
know like a specific routine or you know
what's possible it definitely changes
your perspective on what you should be
doing
and uh
hopefully that's what the podcast does
but that's what the course will be doing
but uh
i don't know i wanted to go sign up
maven.com maven.com they'll see your
face
they'll see my face and it's called the
it's cool and then you have one too on
the i it's called the ideation boot camp
you have one too the the power writing
course this is your third time doing it
my third time doing it yeah and you did
it because you're like uh people liked
it i think god said that you have the
second
highest rated course yeah yeah i forget
who had number one
and uh
you know
uh second place is the best place uh
would they still have somewhere to reach
is it but i'm still at the top
i don't remember which one he said it
was like either one or two i think we
don't uh i don't really care about
highest rated because i was like you
know honestly people's rating will be
more based on themselves like it's just
like actually to use your gym example um
most people aren't like if you're out of
shape it's not because you have the
wrong
workout program and trainer it's because
you know most likely you're not even
going to the gym then if you are going
to the gym you're not working going
consistently if you're not going
consistently if you're even if you are
going constantly you're not working out
with intensity and then comes the
program for back buys and shoulders
that's going to help you get the most
gains and so similarly like
i had um it's like yeah we had a high
rated course but then i looked at i was
like man 15 or 20 percent of people just
never showed up to singapore they paid
and never showed up like damn that's
that's on them like i don't think you
could solve that yeah well you know and
i and i luckily i was wise enough to not
have heartache over that because i was
like that's actually just like a
completely common pattern with all
online education is people don't finish
or they don't start for something that
they'll even pay a bunch of money for
which is really wild so it's like of the
people that come what kind of experience
do they have and then you know six
months nine months later are you still
getting emails being like
yo i used your thing it was you know i
got this outcome out of it that's like
that's the only real true measure of
success and i don't think if 100 people
go into the course it's not going to be
100 people who have that 20 people
aren't even going to show up you know 60
60 of them are gonna forget everything
within a year or never never implement
it and really it's like the 15 to 20 out
of 100 that go like use the thing and
better they're better themselves
yeah it sucks um
do you want to talk about this bitcoin
bitcoin couple what do you want to talk
about
uh i have okay so i have a couple ideas
and then i have a couple random topics
but let's do ideas first
um
so i want to i want to shout out a
couple ideas i saw other people saying
that i thought were kind of interesting
so uh here's the first one so you
invested in this thing stonks.com right
i did and uh explain for people who
don't know what stonks is explain what
it is because it's actually kind of like
pretty dope i had the opportunity to
invest i know the guy super well who
started it uh
he was our biggest competitor when we
were doing my startup
so i was like watching them i kind of
saw how they operate so i knew these
these guys are really good but i didn't
get the idea fully right away and the
valuation was really high because they
have a good track record so i was like
ah okay i'll just pass i'll be a user
not an investor you invested so explain
what it is yeah so it's like shark tank
meets angel list and so angel is a
platform where you can
if anyone starts a company they can go
on and they can get investors and they
make it easy so anyone could invest like
a thousand dollars into your company and
you know what shark tank is and so
basically stocks you could spell the
like the reason i was like is this gonna
work because it's spelled like a joke
yeah yeah it looks like it's like smells
like a meme and like their logo is like
a silly it's like the wall street bets
guy but it's uh so once a how often
what's the cadence now is it every day
or once a week no i don't think it's
every day i think it's once a week or so
so once a week but then they have like
big ones that are once a month and they
do some pre-vetting and they find
interesting startups and all types of
entrepreneur investors are on the phone
or on the call listening and they could
ping in with a question and the whole
audience can watch in real time and so
i've been a guest i've been an investor
or they call it investors where you're
like you're able to ask questions and
i've seen people write checks for fifty
and a hundred thousand dollars live so
the experience is like a live like a
twitch channel basically like an auction
so a startup goes up they pitch their
thing the investor some investors can
ask questions in the chat some are
asking questions live and then you just
see in the chat it's like
so and so is investing ten thousand
dollars so and so is putting in forty
thousand dollars so as i was putting two
thousand dollars in have you seen one
where people they'll raise like i think
somebody raised over 10 million dollars
in 10 minutes is that right i think well
the company raised 10 million stocks
right raised money from guys like me but
and then andreessen horowitz just like
angel investors and then they let their
users invest and they raised like 10 or
15 million dollars in a few hours and so
so what is what's cool is you're a
founder normally your fundraising is
like this multi-month process that
you're almost dreading getting started
with you're like okay i gotta first get
all my ducks in a row and then i gotta
start reaching out and figure making a
list a pipeline to reach out to then
asking people to go out to coffees or
asking for intros and following up and
then pitching and then follow-up
meetings
this shrinks that three-month process
into like seven minutes on stage that's
what's dope about this for the for the
founder for the investor it's also a
time saver right because and
my job is to look at interesting
companies so these guys if they're doing
the hard work of curating them and
putting them on stage and letting me
make a snap decision they're creating a
demo day basically where they they pack
in a bunch of good startups and in
theory right and the whole
it's either going to work because they
curate great startups or it's going to
not work because the great startups
don't want to do this well how did
that's the best
when i talked to him i was like oh this
is a no-brainer i only invested ten
thousand dollars but it was it because i
would i would have done more but uh this
was early on he was like you know it's
twitch for um twitch for angel investing
and i've just seen every other live
streaming pro with too much battle scars
like i've seen so many live stream
products fail
and i was like bro why are you going
into this you know that as well as i do
you know like that's so hard to do i
didn't really understand what he was
saying as the idea and then he i was
like so i asked him a couple questions
he sent me the memo and i saw the
evaluation i was like uh so i think it's
a dope idea okay so now here's the the
riff on it right so that's cool in and
of itself so uh elaine zelby who's been
on the pod a couple times before and she
has she's uh she's an idea person just
like us
so she had this idea that i thought was
pretty cool she goes stonks.com for
other things
it's
i agree can i tell you what one of our
friends uh moyes ali tweeted something
and
it needs to be for homes
stocks for homes
like it's because what the the cool
thing about stonks is you could see what
other what questions other smart people
are asking
and with cars so bring a bring a bring a
trailer my favorite car website it has a
comment section and i could see what
smart people are asking like is this a
67 or a a 1967 or a 1968 because the
1967's offered this thing and the real
collector's items at 68.
you know what i'm just picking that up
but with and with houses it's the same
thing like i i remember
our home like our realtor was saying
like is this made out of stucco or this
other thing and i'm like i don't know
what any of that is and then they're
like did you guys like spray the
installation or is it like i'm like i i
don't know what that means i i i wish i
could see like what questions i knew
smart people were asking and i wish you
could do that live okay
i wish i could i wish and then you could
have an up vote and up vote and i think
i would like it to be for houses so i
think uh okay that's interesting the one
that she had said that i thought was
pretty cool was hiring so stonks.com for
people okay so how does that work so
okay there's general hiring which is
like you know our hiring is like this
like large spectrum from like temp
staffing where i just need like a hourly
employee to show up today and then like
tomorrow they may not come back to like
craigslist to
uh then you get to like linkedin and
indeed which is kind of like mass market
if i'm a
if i'm a you know junior you know or i'm
a mid-level marketing manager i might
get job opportunities on linkedin or
indeed that might be where i go look
then you have like angel list like
vertical places where it's like if i
want a job in startups i won't go to
indeed i'll go to angel list because
that's where the startups hire or the
that's a job board for startups
and so then you have this one like
really interesting thing and then you
have like headhunters which do executive
placements and kind of like uh you know
how do you find a cmo you hire a head
hunter you pay a ton of money and then
they get like a huge cut
so somewhere in there i think there's an
opportunity to
let people hire like top talent live
like this so if you were able to
essentially it's like a reverse job
interview so instead of me going and
interviewing you know what this kind of
reminds me of it's kind of
i'll say it though this kind of sounds
like a like a like a slave yeah i think
you're gonna say you're gonna go there
and actually it makes me it makes me a
little this makes me very uncomfortable
actually like
that i mean like
a talent auction is that what we're
going to call it now dude it's yes at
will bro it's like you get paid or not
like that's like saying employment to
slavery right it's not
um so
so but there was a website i don't know
if you saw it coming out that co it was
called developer auction it was
controversial for this exact reason so
this came out
maybe six years ago or so it ended up um
it got really hot so what they were
doing was they're saying look how
developers are talking
it was like part of yc or they were they
piggybacked on yc in some way i don't
remember if they were a yc company or
what they did was they were like we're
only going to take developers or we're
only going to let yc companies hire from
this place so it's like if you're a dev
who wants to work for a yc company come
on to developer auction you get the
highest dollar bid because these guys
have money and they want great devs
which which was just a little bit of
icing on the douche cake like you're
doing
you're doing it
yeah you're doing an auction now you're
doing it only for yc yeah that's the
late that's the cherry on top of the
douchebag cake the douche de leche cake
yeah so so basically they
they kind of did that and so what was
happening was developers were getting
way more money on this and they also
didn't have to do like a multi-week job
interviewing process it was like they
say hey yeah i was at reddit earlyish
first 40 employees i worked on the fraud
fraud system and this and this i'm
interested in you know companies doing
machine learning and then boom job offer
and job offer at a 20 premium and
developer auction all they had to do was
just say they just had to be like
harvard they just had to be selective
it's like no not any company can just
apply here we're gonna pick and then no
not any developer can apply here we're
going to pick now ultimately i don't
think the model worked because they're
not like the biggest thing ever now i
think they ended up like kind of
pivoting or softening it well all talent
marketplaces are really hard businesses
i think to scale yeah
yeah to scale i think that you could
have a lot of you can have like you can
be a just a recruiter and make millions
of dollars a year you could be just a
job board to make millions of dollars a
year but if you want to be hired.com
then it i don't know if it can it's
really hard to work so i think the trick
here is to do it with something that's
visual so okay stonks is cool because
it's a live video stream so one question
is
what in what
what category
does having a visual screen that's
showing you something
work way better than a resume that was
attached to an email or a job board and
so i think like potentially designers or
even something like more niche than that
like 3d designers video editors graphics
something like that
like this could be maybe how like the
video game industry hires or something
like that i don't know there's there's
something there to doing this oh that's
what she said elaine she said i don't
know i didn't i didn't see which exact
example she had the example of hiring
and i didn't even read on i was like
yeah great idea let me just like riff
off that that's pretty interesting so i
thought that was cool and then i think
there's probably some other areas where
you could do that and i think the trick
is
normally the reason live streaming
products fail is because
the viewers your computer like you don't
want to compete for viewers with people
who are just doing this for leisure
um because they have a ton of options
they can just open tick tock they can
you know go for a walk they can do
anything you need people you need the
viewers of the buy side
for this to be their job
so that's why actually real estate or
real estate investors instead of maybe
even maybe it's not just for buying my
home that i'm going to live in but maybe
it's like multi-family properties get
auctioned off in this way and it's
multi-family investors that are showing
up to to buy pieces of that action or
something like that i think i think that
would be cool i i think i told you this
a hypothesis i had in 2012 or i remember
when i was in the apartment business we
had like a an apartment finder thing and
uh i was like i'm pretty sure that
people it's not that far away that
people are gonna start renting homes and
buying homes without ever seeing them in
person like like like uh this was before
matterport was around
and i think we're there like i i would
buy a house would you buy a house
without seeing it no
i would maybe not mind rent i for sure
would rent a place without seeing it
yeah uh i maybe would buy
but i think i i there's a world i think
where we're gonna buy them soon without
ever seeing a house right
the other one that's kind of all out of
left field here is did you ever watch
the zoom bachelor that some of our
friends did sheila was the zoom bachelor
did you ever watch it
uh no i don't watch that [__] though was
it awesome in real sports well i just
don't watch reality tv you know i watch
good stuff it was like it was like just
people it wasn't real tv even but it was
basically like an object you're shield
he's a he's an investor he's single he's
a good guy we think he's great and so as
a as a joke as a kind of a lark they
created a a live stream
and they curated a bunch of single women
and they were like all right uh and they
basically in the course of an hour it
was like here's six women they introduce
themselves he cuts two it's like all
right of the four women now he's gonna
ask you a question like all right what's
your ideal friday night date what would
we do and then one girl's like oh i
think we would whatever like just how
many times
movie whatever there was like i don't
know like 500 people live watching it
which is a pretty big like live stream
channel pretty good um and this was like
again it was all kind of done as a joke
it was just friends i don't think
that any of them really wanted to date
each other but it was just like to do
the show
but maybe there's something like that
right the bachelor is one of the highest
rated shows ever and then you see stuff
like
uh
there's like a matchmaker show on
netflix that's like indian matchmaker or
something like that as people pay
thousands of dollars to like uh to
matchmakers to find like kind of like
eligible candidates like that's a that's
a that is a niche thing that exists in
every city you and i have a friend you
have and i you and i have a single
friend and i for a gift i nearly bought
him a four thousand dollar matchmaker
and i didn't end up going through with
it because like i don't know if they're
gonna like follow through with this and
that's too much money to spend if they
don't do it and i don't know if they're
gonna find it insulting but i was like i
interviewed this lady three different
times i'm like trying to figure out this
would be the right fit for our friend um
i think that i think they're interesting
i think more people should use that so i
think that
if there was a private version of this
that was you know it was more expensive
um
well so now we're talking about
auctioning off sex
yes
we're talking about auction off the
things people want right so yeah it just
happens to be talent sex things like
that
williams has said this quote ev williams
started uh twitter and blogger before
that and medium now
he uh he goes here's the recipe for a
billion dollar internet company have you
heard this quote before he goes here's
here's the recipe for a billion dollar
internet company
take a human desire preferably one
that's been around for hundreds of years
use technology to remove steps
and
that was his whole thing he's like you
know and so he's like that's how i built
blogger twitter everything else like
twitter took out a bunch of steps for a
human desire that people had and um and
i think that's just like you know sounds
stupidly simple but is actually true
let me tell you about something that i
saw i did not research this at all for
this talk but i wanted to just bring it
up because we were talking something
about something similar um i'm trying to
find i'm trying to figure out how i'm
going to manage so i bought this farm i
need to like get a manager to help run
it and there's these property management
companies but they don't really have
like the touch
it's a little sterile and like to make
this work the way i want it to work i
want someone that's a little bit more
close to it um so in your brain in your
head
when i think of an outsourced person
like what's like the image that you're
that i that you get can you just trying
to give you can't explain that to me
no no just just tell me like
outsource vr uh a virtual assistant yeah
like i don't know somebody in the
philippines or india who's you know
sitting at a desk uh you know stepping
away for for like in a call center or
style
style exactly
okay now when i'd say um military spouse
military spouse what comes to your mind
um
patriot a woman in america uh white
blonde hair
uh speaks great english sitting you know
in the comfort of her you know her home
office uh talking to you know customers
what attributes are there uh any loyal
organized um
trustworthy things like that
exactly so there's this company called
squared away
so google squared away we've talked
about the one here before by the way yes
we have uh but i didn't get it we talked
about one episode we did one we did one
episode where we talked about um
like
a cool way to come up with a type of
company that you want is uh who would
you want to hire like what demographic
you want to hire so who do you want to
show right that's another one right yeah
you're ultimately gonna be serving a
customer and so it helps a lot if you
care about them and and understand them
and want want more of them to be around
you every day
so
go uh what's it called go squared away i
don't know why it's called go squared
away or maybe it's just called the
business squared away the domain they
just couldn't get squared.com probably
and it's the most expensive the cheapest
tier is two hundred dollars for five
hours great copy on this website look at
this so what okay great it's great so
what's another what's another
outsourcing company
can we just find like up work like uh go
to um let me just google like
outsourcing
or let's say virtual
assistant for uh virtual assistant
if they show up on the top of google
they might have good copywriting but
while you're looking for that so the
copywriting on this page so you go to uh
squared away it says the best company
perk is personal assistance for your
entire team our
our team of military spouses gives you
your time back and it's a picture of a
lady holding up her sign
waiting for her husband to get off the
plane from like coming home
this screen so ben open up flexjobs.com
this is this is just a perfect example
flex job is not terrible right like it's
it showed up at the top of google it's
not i don't never use the service i'm
not saying that i'm saying just the
website it's not horrible
um
but it's not special and it doesn't make
you feel anything right so i can't so
just compare the feelings okay so and if
you're on you should be watching on
youtube to be able to see this so
if i go to flex jobs i see this kind of
like blue and orange tacky site with
stock photos of literally
men and women in corporate running away
running away
like we're doing a ballet leap away from
you and then it says the number one job
site to find vetted remote work from
home and flexible job opportunities
since 2007. that's that okay
great and then it and then it's like
good morning america cnn wall street
journal whatever
okay so this is
it's okay and the headline is find a
better way to work generic vague doesn't
make me feel anything
um
and you know just the this is this
doesn't do it now go back to go straight
away go squared away what do they say
the best company perk
personal assistance for your entire team
so already they're selling the benefit
right you who's coming here is probably
looking to hire a personal assistant um
and they
um and they focus on they frame it as
this is the best perk you can offer your
employees instead of just find a
personal assistant which assumes you
already know you want a personal
assistant they sell you the benefit of
having a personal assistant that you're
providing the best perk for your team
then they have this like black and white
photo of like a military mom holding a
child's hand with a sign
you know uh you know like i'm thinking
of thinking of you daddy as you know the
as he leaves for the plane she's like at
an airport hangar right like an
emotional scene and she seems like
somebody who you would want to support
you would love to like help this woman
out and that she seems like somebody who
you would want not like you know this
stock photo of a corporate person
running away from you
how crazy is that this is beautiful
branding because i don't know how many
people are in the military but like a
military spouse is not like i mean uh
that's a
it's not that ex uh uh it's not that
rare so like i may hire these people for
doing all types of jobs and they are a
military spouse but as soon as they
brand it as i i'm like oh well you
definitely are a good person exactly
like even though i've i they it doesn't
necessarily mean they're a great person
but for some reason i think that even
though you're a good person you're
bringing this company up yeah right
bonus points yeah you're you're uh you
know you get free free virtue for for
having brought this company up as
something cool is this beautiful
branding or what like why did we even
why did we talk about this before we
talked about before same thing we were
talking about the stay-at-home mom
workforce and like how do you tap into
that like labor markets that are under
underutilized so excess talent that
doesn't that's that's looking for a job
and we talked about you know what could
you do with stay-at-home moms and then
we brought this up and they actually
shared the clip because they were like
hey this was cool we got like featured
on this thing and so that's how i
remember that we've talked about it
before but uh
how did we get here what were you
talking about so you were talking about
that oh well i don't i don't remember we
were i think you're talking about like
talent right like talent marketplaces
and i was and i just i i didn't even
research i'm i signed up for uh what's
it called get square
squared away i entered i'm waiting for
them to call me back but i signed up
because i but when i went to it i was
like
oh my god i'm in love i want i want to
hire this woman in the picture i need
her i hire if i use the service it like
washes away the fact that i like don't
do compost
that i forgot to recycle that bottle
and i feel like the woman's just gonna
have my back so hard like she's just
gonna like just
so much loyalty she's not your spouse
dude
[Laughter]
no but she's my partner that's like how
i feel
and i just thought they don't they this
website i've never seen i've never felt
this way about a woman
oh jonathan brought my wife you were
talking about managing your ranch so you
were saying you might use this instead
or just kind of
it reminded you that nobody's doing that
in the past
space of making you feel the way that
this makes you feel about assistance is
that right
i don't even remember the angle that i
had but yes i think i'm going to use
this to manage my ranch but i thought i
thought that
and good example of a landing page so uh
all right so let's let's go to another
one so
can i tell you uh all right i'll do a
quick one i just want to get your take
on this so i followed this guy uh and i
don't know if this is his name because
it sounds like a fake name i've been
talking to him i just sort of realized i
don't know if this is his real name uh
but his his twitter handle is pure rich
and um
and i don't know if he's if his name is
pure rich his name is al
okay his name is
his name is peter richardson
uh
peter richardson so that's his name uh
so anyways he he's uh he's another guy
who tried to talent marketplace and now
he's pivoted to something sweet
so
uh he had initially he had a yc company
and it like didn't work out and then he
like as a like they just needed money
and they were like yo we just shut down
our company um you can you can hire us
we're a yc duo you can just hire us
we'll do a project for you for like as a
contractor for like two weeks cost money
but like you're getting a yc founder duo
where can you hire that oh my god and i
was like dude this is [__] amazing i
was like i would love to hire yc founder
duos and i was like if you think about
it like some number maybe 20 30 40 of yc
companies are gonna shut down and like
you know those people might just go get
jobs but actually it might be cool for
them to like continue to brand
themselves as a yc company as a yc
founders
and be able to be higher be able for
hire so they did that for a little bit
and i thought that was cool that's how i
got in touch with him
now he's doing something called cal.com
have you seen this it's a competitor to
calendly
cal dot com great number domain just
email
all right all right so scheduling
infrastructure for absolutely everyone
so basically what they are is we've
talked about calendly calendly before
calendly basically gives you a little a
link that's a calendar where somebody
can book you and so that's great for
like a salesperson who's like uh hey i
would love to chat about you know how we
might be able to help you out here's a
link to my calendar grab a time that
works for you and it like lets you go
pick a time it emails both of you a
calendar invited like takes care of the
whole like booking process so calendly
had become like a
i think a billion dollar plus company
uh
uh recently two billion dollar company
and they're aren't they like weren't
they bootstrapped for like a really long
time or something crazy they had like
yeah the guy was an african immigrant
who
uh bootstrapped it for like 20 million
in revenue raised around at like a
billion and then recently raised another
round at like two or three or four so
that business is working so cal.com i
think is a great competitor so i'm gonna
invest in this because i believe in this
model that they're doing which is
commercial open source software so cal
calendly is not open source cal.com is
is open source what does that mean that
means you can
hey you can read the source code b you
can basically like self-host it so a lot
of companies don't want their kind of
like data and for information in the
hands of another company they like to be
able to self-host the software that
they're using and also be able to fork
it or remix it in some way that like is
customizable to them
and so
these guys are growing fast i switched
over from calmly now i use cal is it
awesome yeah it's a sick product and you
could you embed these on your website so
it's like if you have a website you're
like i don't know uh you give people
you're you're a lawyer you need people
like instead of saying here's a contact
us form and then one of our humans will
reach out to you and then we'll try to
schedule a time and by that time you
already forgot how interested you were
so what this does is do just embed your
your booking calendar right here
and it reads your existing calendar so
it won't let anybody book a time that's
already taken and you can set up rules
like don't do meeting like i need a
minimum 10 minute gap in between
meetings or whatever right you set some
rules
you just embed that right here so in the
heat of the moment when somebody's
interested you can grab that lead right
away to get them booked for a meeting
and so
do but how do you use it because you're
not a company you're so i'll use it
either for if i'm going to invest in if
i'm if i'm doing talking to founder and
it's like hey yeah i would love to chat
sometime next week all right you know
here's my calendar feel free to grab any
time that works for you um and some
people find that like offensive whatever
i don't know people are too sensitive
about [__] like you know just trying to
be it's we're trying to try to make it
flexible for the other person to pick
whatever time works for them without
requiring for email back and forth or
pawning you off to my assistant who's
gonna like take it from here um and
you'll have to email them four times to
find a time that works and so
uh so i use it for that i'll also use it
for like random meetings so i'll have a
calendly that's just you know like i'll
have like you know just backslash sean
and i'll put like a one hour of random
meetings once per month that anybody on
the internet can go book and so those
are ways that
that i just add a little like randomness
and serendipity into my life that's like
in a controlled fashion of when when it
can happen
dude this is cool you they did a really
funny flex so if you go to the website
you see a thing that says claim your
username
and
when you refresh consistently you see
different
names in the autofilled example
and it's all people who are well known
and i bet
are investors of the company and you see
that and you're like oh well james
beshear said neval this person yeah
those guys are they are investors
yeah isn't that funny how they did that
yeah that's cool and i think
if you look by the way this is a common
model there's a closed source winner and
there's an open source winner for a
bunch of different categories and
software so this is just like a very
simple
way to find good deals is if you if you
missed out or you see a great company
that's like completely closed source
just google for the commercial open
source company and then if they have a
great team behind them there's usually
like a separate segment of the market
that's quite large that they can attack
just by going from this like open source
self-hosted model
these guys have exploded they went from
like nothing to a lot of traffic they're
growing fast yeah you should invest too
i can introduce you
yeah do it i would love i love this
stuff can we talk about the bitcoin
thing please yeah let's do it by the way
i didn't even say his idea all right
that whole thing wasn't even the thing
oh
what's the idea what he tweeted out he
goes
um i wish somebody built this called the
anywhere school i think this is just
kind of interesting so he goes the
anywhere school is for people who want
to travel the world but they don't want
their kids to education to suffer so
here's how it goes
and he put out just like a one-page pdf
memo of just like here's what it would
be if anyone's building this like you
know take this and run with it and let
me know
and so what it was is like
you join a classroom but it's a
traveling classroom around the world so
the classroom's gonna be like we're
gonna spend three months this year in
paris you know three months in bali and
three months in wherever you know like
thailand and three months in in south
africa and the family and the kids go
with it so the kids get a consistent
structure the teacher stays the same
their friends stay the same
but they get to experience a year of
world travel
and um and so it's like for prep for
people who want to have travel but don't
want to wait or don't want to trade off
their kids stability and education i
actually think that's a kind of a cool
idea i don't think this is like a huge
huge business maybe it's bigger than i
think but i just think that's awesome
and that should be pretty neat
so the anywhere
i'm on board and that
and and i also think that's a while i
was googling anywhere school and uh
there's nothing interesting it's a great
great name right i think it's a great
name it's great okay let's let's do the
bitcoin
wait really quick before we get to that
what were you gonna say about strauss
zelnick dude you're gonna love this so
you know i i i know so
explain who he is yeah so there's this
guy named
so there's this guy named strauss how do
you pronounce this i think it's right
zelnick uh i'm i'm just doing this off
memory so correct me i think he's the
ceo of uh
uh take two interactive which is
basically the owner or creator of
uh
grand theft auto and like
in like eight other games that are of
that caliber so like uh maybe like a
five or ten billion dollar a year
company that owns like the biggest video
games in the world
and he's probably in his mid to late 50s
and he looks like a gi joe
so he's this like jacked dude who gets
up at like 5 a.m in new york and works
out really hard and a lot of people are
invited to go work out with them um but
it's all like high caliber
get average that's exactly right so he
created a kind of like
i call it the breakfast club but it's
basically like a morning
a morning workout club and ben you can
google this so there's a a youtube video
that's called strauss zellnex invitation
only fitness club
it's a two minute video so it's just
like really easy to watch and you can
see basically um when you go to it it's
like
he goes
he goes i made a decision that i was
going to treat fitness as a like
important part of my schedule so like
okay i'm a ceo if i had a board meeting
i'm not going to skip it or move it
because i'm feeling tired right so he's
like i'm gonna treat fitness the same
way that i would treat uh like like a
like a meeting or family time or
whatever like i'm gonna put it like
first order importance
and then he's like but you know how do i
like juice this up and i'm a big fan of
this this is a big life hack which is
multiply activities so
you know like i've done this before too
which is you want to
hang out with cool people or have
friends but you you don't you know you
only have maybe like one hour of
recreation a day so are you gonna choose
fitness or friends well even better let
me just find friends who like fitness
and let's work out together right you do
this all the time i do this too and so
what he did was he was like all right
we're gonna wake up at five or six in
the morning um in new york and they go
somewhere and do a different fitness
related activity it doesn't matter how
fit you are although the pictures that
they share like everybody's got like a
six-pack
everyone's jacked and then it's called
like the program and it's basically like
kind of networking kind of friends
hanging out and kind of fitness all at
once uh but instead of being kind of
each of them actually that's the wrong
way to say it it's
it's like the 100 of each of those
because when you work out with somebody
it's like the new york banker exactly
and so they get up they do something
different every day
and um and he like would pay for it so
he's like all right if we're doing this
activity like money is not going to be
the object that stops somebody from
doing this so i'll just cover it for our
whole group and we'll just go do
whatever the heck activity we want to do
and so the guy's in great shape he's
like oh i love it because i get to hang
out with like a bunch of like really
interesting motivated like kind of 20 or
30 year olds that are like pushing me to
a be more fit and like don't be the old
man but also like these are really
talented ambitious people who are who
see the world differently than me right
and so i thought this is just a
fantastic idea and um bev tell me a
friend of a friend of a friend of his
was was doing it and uh
i was invited when i was in new york but
for some reason the scheduling didn't
work out i couldn't go
yeah they get up early that's the beauty
of everything right so how do you
prevent this from being just the
moochers show up who just want you know
just the networking and all that you
make it at 6am uh and you make the
fitness thing kind of hard
that's the filter that will self-select
for the type of person you want to be
around for this kind of thing
i just hate working out at 6 00 a.m i
hate working out i thought you'd be all
about it because you know the harder the
better for you
i
yeah like i would go but like the
problem with
my my issue with working out at 6 a.m
means i've got to wake up at like 5 20
which means i've gotta go go to bed at
like nine and if i have to go to bed at
nine i'm in bed at nine and i'm so
anxious saying to myself if i don't go
to sleep now like i'm not gonna be able
to wake up and i get so anxious about
waking up early that it makes it not
funny totally tell you you know what i
mean
i i
i don't work out early i work out as a
midday break every day so i
i work out like that two p.m every day
and uh and actually i pretty much stop
working at that point then i come back
and i start working again at like 11 p.m
or midnight and so i don't have to wake
up early and i have a bunch of energy
when i do that but the the the takeaway
for this for me um the voice in my head
when i heard this i go
oh yeah i forgot sean
build your cult
and um i think that's just like the take
away i think you gotta build your cult
it's like do the things you want to do
uh open them up so that others can do
them with you
do them in a way that's like slightly
hard and everybody's making a bit of a
everyone's stretching themselves in some
way
because that's the sacrifice and the
buy-in the blood oath that you want in
your cult
and like just [__] build your cult be
around the type person you want to be
around dude this is this is why
you're building your cult that's a great
example i was doing it like general
assembly guy what did he do uh
daybreaker yeah daybreaker it was like a
5 a.m party with no alcohol you're cold
right like what do i want i want to
start my day yeah
a bunch of energy dance blah blah blah
but i don't want alcohol and music i
don't like nightclubs so i'm gonna bring
i'm gonna build my own cult that's
awesome uh all right did you have
anything else you wanted to do or should
we wrap it
sounds good
[Music]